leider leider weg und es hat nicht
funktioniert
fakt ist gott oh gott
hier auf meinem channel die kinozeit ist
erstmal zurückgeschraubt worden und die
minecraft zeit wird jetzt wieder
forciert damit wieder mehr minecraft
gespielt und es geht weiter hier mit
einer runde energie hat heute je nachdem
wie gut es läuft wie schnell es läuft
mache ich einfach so ein best of three
was das heißen soll
ich spiele eine runde hinter games eine
runde survival games und eine runde
kriegsbeginns so das hab ich mir gedacht
und ich muss euch einiges erzählen
leute es ging wirklich drunter und
drüber und das ist nicht alles so
gelaufen wie es laufen sollte
aber dass jetzt gleich mehr und zwar ich
fange erst mal daran wie ich gerade auf
immer so ich nehme nicht gerade wie
gedacht einfach mit dem neuen pc auf
sondern dies nehme momentan mit dem
neuen pc und mit meinem laptop
zeitgleich auch weil es anders nicht
geht ja ich nehme auf meinem neuen pc
derzeit fraps in diesem moment nämlich
raps auf und auch die city um einem auf
meinem laptop nämlich wunders movie
maker auf weil wenn ich auch noch bundes
movie maker auf meinem desktop aufnehme
dann legte er an geht es nicht das ist
alles ziemlich da hab ich eigentlich
nicht so gut drauf und ich muss jetzt
auf jeden fall einen neuen pc kaufen
noch einen neuen wer hätte das gedacht
weil dieser pc einfach nicht ausreicht
muss man schauen wir wichtig mit dem er
mache ob ich denn wieder zurückgeben
kann an meinen kollegen oder keine
ahnung auf jeden fall brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich neun ich hat formen von
csl zu holen der mit so einem ziemlich
guten 16 gigabyte rahmen
so jetzt mit dem betreff lodenfrey um
den kleinen grünen sind mit viel spaß so
sagte benedikt xvi
okay gefunden dass man das was ich sage
heute ist der pc hat 16 gigabyte rahmen
einen intel 4097 k also ein ziemlich
geiles prozessor ungefähr einen der
westen den internet gerade zu bieten hat
top.de schon unter den top 3 und ja dazu
noch eine gtx 750 keine 760 glaube eine
750 reicht aus glaubt die grafik hat ist
gar nicht so wichtig hier in für
minecraft ich glaube dass einfach nur
für die ganze moderne aufnehmen ist ein
guter prozess und ein guter
arbeitsspeicher wichtig und hat eine
ordentliche grafikkarten sehen wir die
gtx 750 auf jeden fall ordentlich
schreibt mir gerne mal die kommentare
aus ihr davon haltet also das denn
was wir haben sie habe ich der schaden
gekommen
keine ahnung na ja ich arbeite ja wie
gesagt ich nehme gerade auf laptop und
desktop zeitweise auf und schneidet das
nachher auf dem laptop wahrscheinlich
weil ich auf dem desktop noch nicht dort
versteckt er ist dass hunderte warteten
auf dem desktop es auf und aus dem web
koppensteiner das nach wahrscheinlich
auf dem laptop steht das einfach über
per usb mal schauen wie das sich beim
schnitt gestalten wird wie das wirklich
keine ahnung aber ich hoffe mal so was
gut ist wenn wir es gerade morgens bis
morgens ein bisschen frühjahr wir früher
mit donnerstag und es geht mittlerweile
halbwegs wieder das aufnehmen und als
wie gesagt es ist keine dauerhafte
lösung sondern er auch manches gar nicht
weil es echt gerne mal oder der papa ich
hätte ich gerne mal bogen dann was mach
ich schaue die küsterei und finde einen
bogen
außerdem sprechen
dafür findet bisschen sich auf der
packung gehen denn ich bin ja bin ich
doch leider leider weg und es hat nicht
funktioniert
fackler sofort westlotto gott oh gott
wie soll ich diese person nicht gesehen
alice die ady verwandelt deswegen habe
ich sie nicht gesehen weil system
verwandelt du denkst du bist du denkst
du kannst mich verarschen
dann gehe ich male gern zähnchen
aufpassen wie ich in so einem winzigen
box hat ok jetzt ist auch weg alles da
kein problem so den titel echt schwer zu
treffen also einen münchen gemacht ist
es schon fast okay weil diese wünschen
so schwer zu treffen sind wegen ihrer
winzigen hit box aber das geht auch
alles funktioniert schon
also packen belgiens können das ist aus
gold macht ausübt hat keinen bock auf
gold nicht so im steinigen modus spieler
so weiter
die speed blog hier mitnehmen das sieht
doch ganz lecker aus jetzt sind wir das
volk darunter
mit einem dicken arsch klatscher hier im
wasser gelandet
wir wissen schon dass sie ohne zu ende
bringen dass wir da noch oft erwartet
einer im ernst mit dem ernst leute im
ernst das ist doch nicht euer ernst
könnte nicht machen ihr könnt nicht wie
heute ist das denn bitte ohne witz ohne
witz wie häufig ist das camp der da
unten junge kämpft er da unten wo unter
unter dem tower wo sich eine hoch
gesteckt hatten was darunter fällt oder
wie oder wie es sonst erklären dass sie
so nah dran war verstehe es nicht
na ja auf jeden fall haben es jetzt
geschafft wir sind ihm entkommen
wo aber das war echt das war echt knapp
das war jetzt wirklich wirklich knapp es
geschafft kann man sich beschweren
können die nächstens vergelten nicht
voller leben dann ist vielleicht nicht
so unsere vergeltung fantasien
sollte mir ganz gut erwischt ja sehr gut
ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen dass ich
bisschen weniger schweige beim camp man
konzentriert sich aber so krass dass ihr
das selbst kennt also was ihr selbst
fängt auch videos macht aber so auf
jeden fall ist es echt so muss ich bin
irgendwie länder games noch krasseren
zweifel games weil man da so wie alle
effekte mit einem b-team aus unsere
mental voll auf der höhe sein denke ich
da ist man noch ein bisschen mehr
beansprucht als beim normalen zwei
beginnt deswegen finde ich das immer ein
bisschen von einer session immer ein
bisschen kompliziert aber ich wissen ich
denke sich alle hoch eine jacke 956 ist
das ist ein trauriger das hat außer den
holzmarkt
ich hoffe dass keine rüstung hat sich
beim bauern keine rüstung geholt ok go
live
na gut das war es schon das war's schon
wieder nehmen wir auf ich schon mal kurz
belastet die sieben minuten perfekt so
leute sind wieder ich habe jetzt ein
paar testaufnahmen 8 und ja es scheint
das ist einfach viel zu lang weil hier
ist es geht so weiter machen wir bei 20
minuten oder so und das ist einfach zu
lang wegen ablauf erinnern und service
bescheid und deshalb würde ich sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat könnt ihr
gerne einen daumen nach oben da las ihr
könnt in die kommentare schreiben
was ich gerade so durch den kopf geht
und dann sehen was beim nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht's gut wunsch